[Aplausos]
[Música]
Hasta qué punto los Estados Unidos de
América están preparados para mantener
su dominio militar ha puesto de
manifiesto la Guerra de Ucrania algún
problema serio en las fuerzas armadas de
Estados Unidos por qué en Washington de
repente tantos analistas parecen
Inquietos y ojo porque en el contexto
geopolítico actual estas preguntas
cobran más importancia que nunca fijaos
si no en lo que decía en 2022 el
almirante Charles Richard por aquel
entonces Ni más ni menos que comandante
del mando estratégico de los Estados
Unidos atentos esta crisis de Ucrania en
la que estamos inmersos ahora mismo es
tan solo el calentamiento la crisis más
grande está por llegar y no va a pasar
mucho tiempo antes de que nos pongan a
prueba de formas que no nos han puesto a
prueba en mucho tiempo almirante Charles
Richard ex comandante del mando
estratégico de los Estados Unidos ahora
bien A qué se refiere Exactamente no sé
al fin y al cabo si algo ha puesto de
manifiesto la guerra de Ucrania ha sido
precisamente la enorme superioridad del
armamento el entrenamiento y la
financiación occidental respecto al que
era uno de sus grandes adversarios la
Rusia de Vladimir Putin no es así
entonces por qué Parece existir de
repente tanta preocupación ahí realmente
motivos
[Aplausos]
queridos amigos y amigas el ejército de
los Estados Unidos es la fuerza de
combate más poderosa que jamás haya
existido sin embargo la Guerra de
Ucrania ha puesto sobre la mesa y
acentuado algunas importantísimas
debilidades que ahora generan mucha pero
que muchísima inquietud en este vídeo os
vamos a contar Cuáles son exactamente
las 5 grandes debilidades que hoy por
hoy presenta la capacidad militar de los
Estados Unidos de América la mayor
superpotencia económica política y
militar del mundo pero antes una
pregunta te haces una idea de lo que te
estás perdiendo por no usar surfshark lo
principal y más importante la seguridad
al navegar por internet surfshark te
protege cifrando tu actividad Online
para que nadie pueda rastrear ni robar
tus datos bloquea anuncios y malware con
Clean web y protege tus cuentas de
correo electrónico con Surf alert
notificándote si se filtra cualquier
información personal pero espera porque
aún hay más surfshark es la primera VPN
comercial con servidores en más de 100
países distintos lo que significa que
puedes abrir un nuevo Universo de
contenidos restringidos Según tu
ubicación con un solo clic además con
una misma cuenta podrá registrar todos
los dispositivos que quieras sin límite
tu teléfono tablet las Smart TV el
portátil vamos aquí entre nosotros que
puedes compartir la cuenta con tus
mejores amigos pagando así cada uno unos
pocos céntimos al mes pero lo mejor de
todo por ser parte de la comunidad
visualpolitik podrás disfrutar de un 83%
de descuento y 3 meses gratis usando el
código politic acabado en K y dicho esto
continuemos con nuestro vídeo de hoy
cuestión de prioridades
los Estados Unidos se encuentran
viviendo un histórico punto de inflexión
la Rusia de Putin ha perdido los papeles
Corea del Norte es cada vez una amenaza
más importante Irán está a punto de
hacerse con la bomba nuclear y sobre
todo la República popular china aspira a
disputarle la primera Plaza como la gran
superpotencia del mundo las amenazas a
las que nos enfrentamos hoy son más
formidables que en cualquier otro
momento de los últimos 20 años Mike
Rogers presidente del comité de
servicios armados de la cámara de
representantes Quizás por eso Estados
Unidos tiene con mucha diferencia el de
presupuesto militar más alto de todo el
planeta sin embargo pese a ello algunos
analistas como los de la fundación
afirman que actualmente la preparación
de las fuerzas armadas de este país es
débil Estados Unidos gasta mucho pero
también tiene muchos muchísimos más
compromisos que ningún otro país además
Estados Unidos gasta mucho en términos
absolutos pero cada vez menos en
términos relativos si tenemos en cuenta
la inflación los crecientes costes de
equipos y salarios el nivel de gasto de
los últimos años puede no ser tan
elevado de hecho se ajustamos los
presupuestos militares por el nivel de
precios de cada país por ejemplo lo que
cuesta tener un soldado o lo que cuestan
los suministros la historia cambia
bastante
[Música]
fijaos por ejemplo en este gráfico de
2019 la primera columna es el gasto
militar de Estados Unidos la segunda es
la suma de los gastos militares de China
a la India y Rusia como veis el gasto
militar norteamericano es mucho más
grande pero qué ocurre si ajustamos los
presupuestos por el nivel de precios de
Estados Unidos pues ocurre exactamente
esto la superpotencia norteamericana
sigue gastando más que nadie pero la
diferencia ya no es tan abultado
y en cualquier caso a diferencia de
otros países las fuerzas armadas ya no
son la gran prioridad de Washington no
me creéis Así es como ha evolucionado el
presupuesto Federal en los últimos años
como veis el gobierno de Estados Unidos
gasta cada vez más de hecho en términos
de pib el gasto no militar ha crecido
casi un 50% desde comienzos de siglo ha
pasado del 12,6% del pib al 18,6 sin
embargo no ha ocurrido lo mismo con el
gasto militar una partida cada vez más
pequeña dentro del presupuesto Federal
fijaos
de esta forma el gasto militar cada vez
representa una parte menos importante
del presupuesto Federal además
últimamente el presupuesto militar
incluye partidas mil y millonarias para
cosas como limitar las emisiones de CO2
y otros gases de efecto invernadero del
ejército lo cual puede estar bien o mal
pero que está claro No determina la
capacidad militar por ejemplo este
documento que veis por aquí es el plan
de implementación de la estrategia de
cambio climático del ejército para los
años
2023-2027 y esto es tan solo un ejemplo
por supuesto esta falta de prioridad
tiene consecuencias
por ejemplo los últimos grandes planes
de modernización del ejército se
llevaron a cabo la década de los 80 hace
ya casi 40 años hablamos por ejemplo de
la aparición del tanque M1 abrams los m2
Bradley o los helicópteros Black hope y
Apache sí evidentemente se han hecho
mejoras y sigue muy por delante de sus
rivales pero hablamos de equipos que
aparecieron ya hace casi 40 años y eso
es mucho tiempo
[Música]
y ojo porque podemos encontrar una
situación muy similar en la fuerza aérea
desde 1987 el número de cazas
bombarderos aviones de reabastecimiento
o de transporte no solo se ha reducido
más de un 30%, sino que hoy los aviones
son de media mucho muchísimo más viejos
para que os hagáis una idea la edad
promedio de los aviones de la fuerza
aérea de Estados Unidos es de
29,4 años Sí sí lo habéis escuchado bien
casi 30 años
[Música]
de hecho la media de algunos aviones
como los bombarderos b-52 o los aviones
de reabastecimiento kc 135 superan los
60 años la Edad Media de los f-15c es de
37,8 años y la de los f-16 versiones Cid
superan los 31 y sí lo sé la mayoría
están actualizados pero hablamos en
general de equipos muy viejos y eso se
nota Pues bien todo esto ha hecho que
muchos analistas tengan miedo de que con
las fuerzas armadas pasen lo mismo que
ha pasado con las infraestructuras que
pasen de ser excelentes a ser
terriblemente viejas que como Washington
tiene otras prioridades sobre dónde y
cómo gastar el dinero poco a poco los
sistemas militares vayan envejeciendo
hasta niveles alarmantes es decir que el
miedo Es que el cada vez mayor gasto
social se trague todo lo demás
sorprendidos pues no hemos hecho más que
empezar prestad mucha atención al
segundo gran problema un problema que la
Guerra de Ucrania ha puesto sobre la
mesa atentos
alerta mucha burocracia poca munición
la mayoría de las personas que viven en
este planeta saben que Estados Unidos
tiene el ejército más poderoso del mundo
y que lo ha tenido desde hace décadas lo
que no se sabe tanto es que llegado el
caso estas fuerzas armadas podrían
enfrentarse a un grave problema la falta
de munición y suministros Esto es algo
que se ha visto muy bien en la Guerra de
Ucrania una guerra moderna gran escala
es y será ante todo Una guerra
Industrial es decir un ejército no sólo
tiene que tener las mejores armas
también tiene que tener garantizados los
suministros incluidas lógicamente las
municiones
[Música]
por ejemplo se calcula que Estados
Unidos ha enviado Ucrania cerca de un
tercio de todas sus existencias de
misiles antitanque javelyn y misiles
antiaéreos stinger para que os hagáis
una idea a los ritmos de producción
actuales de los chavelin harían falta
más de siete años para reponer el stock
entregado Ucrania en el caso de los
stingers si nos fijamos en su nivel de
producción antes de que este se
detuviera por completo hablamos de más
de 13 largos años
y la pregunta es pero cómo demonios es
esto posible
Pues bien Lo cierto es que durante años
no se prestó mucha atención a la cadena
de suministros digamos que lo
prioritario era comprar y desarrollar
nuevos equipos de guerra nuevos aviones
nuevos portaaviones nuevos blindados El
problema es que ante la falta de
contratos la capacidad de fabricar
municiones y sistemas de armas no tan
llamativos se redujo que estamos mucho
dinero en algunos grandes sistemas muy
exquisitos y no gastamos ni nos
centramos tanto en las municiones
necesarias para apoyarlos nadie está
comprando los sistemas de armas
necesarios para participar en algo que
no sea una batalla muy pero que muy
corto plazo gregory hayex director
ejecutivo de Ryder la cuestión es que
tampoco es que el ejército Aparentemente
lo necesitara claro siempre cuando
hablemos de conflictos como el de Irak o
Afganistán donde la superioridad militar
es tan clara que no hace falta grandes
despliegues sin embargo si por ejemplo
pensamos en China y un hipotético
conflicto en Taiwán la cosa cambia por
completo en esas circunstancias la
necesidad de municiones podría superar
con creces las existencias actuales y la
capacidad de producción
[Música]
por ejemplo según una serie de análisis
y juegos de guerra desarrollados por el
centro de estudios estratégicos e
internacionales un importante Finn Tank
norteamericano en el caso de un choque
con china Estados Unidos podría quedarse
sin municiones de largo alcance y armas
de precisión en menos de una semana eso
es por ejemplo lo que explica
exactamente noticias como esta la marina
de los Estados Unidos Busca aumentar
drásticamente la producción de misiles
el problema queridos amigos amigas es
que cambiar esto lleva mucho tiempo se
necesita mano de obra especializada
invertir en nuevas fábricas o ampliar
las existentes construir las redes
logísticas etcétera etcétera pensad por
ejemplo en el caso del misil stranger el
director ejecutivo de ration la empresa
que lo fabrica dijo que reiniciar su
producción tomaría no menos de 18 meses
para colmo no se trata solo de Estados
Unidos la inmensa mayor parte de sus
aliados están en una situación muy
similar con lo que el problema se
multiplica
echemos por ejemplo un vistazo al caso
de Ucrania fijaos
según muchos analistas Ucrania tendría
que estar lanzando cerca de 250.000
proyectiles de artillería cada mes sin
embargo están disparando menos de la
mitad porque pues porque las 12 empresas
europeas que fabrican la munición
necesaria apenas tienen capacidad para
fabricar 650.000 proyectiles en todo un
año y en el caso de Estados Unidos la
producción se sitúa en aproximadamente
20.000 proyectiles por mes
pero eso ni siquiera es todo además
resulta muy difícil encontrar algunos
componentes básicos que estén fabricados
en Estados Unidos y no en países como
china Lo que se considera un riesgo
claro para la seguridad nacional por
ejemplo en septiembre de 2022 se
detuvieron por un tiempo todas las
entregas de nuevos f-35 el motivo
encontraron una aleación fabricada en
China en algunos componentes Pues bien
De momento la administración incluyó en
su petición presupuestaria al congreso
un incremento de más del 50% para
comprar misiles y municiones con no solo
de reponer el stock entregado a Ucrania
sino también para empezar a restablecer
las cadenas de suministro en esta línea
la producción de proyectiles para
artillería por ejemplo se espera que se
incremente un 500% en apenas 2 años
en
workings
ahora bien pensáis que aquí terminan
todos los problemas de la cadena de
producción pues estáis muy pero que muy
equivocados fijaos según un nuevo
informe del proceso presupuestario del
pentágono es demasiado lento para vencer
a China china está recibiendo nuevas
armas más rápido que Estados Unidos de
esta forma el tiempo que el pentágono
necesita para detectar una necesidad y
adjudicar un contrato sea multiplicado
por 7 desde los años 50 digamos que el
proceso se ha vuelto demasiado lento y
Pesado
y esto nos lleva directamente al tercer
gran problema de las fuerzas armadas de
Estados Unidos uno del que ya os hemos
hablado aquí en visualpolitik la
hiperconcentración del sector atentos
[Música]
el control de los gigantes
desde la caída de La Unión soviética El
número de contratistas principales ha
pasado de más de 80 a prácticamente
estos cinco grandes grupos que veis en
pantalla no hace muchos años teníamos
cinco veces más contratistas y había más
competencia y más creatividad que en
calver congresista republicano por
California es decir que con el paso del
tiempo que en 1961 el presidente
Eisenhower ya bautizó como el complejo
militar Industrial ahora ha quedado bajo
el control de unos pocos gigantes
Prácticamente todo pasa por ellos si por
ejemplo hace 30 años el departamento de
defensa podía contar con ocho
proveedores de aviones militares hoy
solo puedo hacerlo con tres Boeing login
Martin y northman en el caso de los
misiles el número ha pasado de 8 a 3 hoy
por hoy el 90% de los misiles
norteamericanos son fabricados por tan
solo tres empresas Boeing login Martin y
ration y en ciertos casos de
subcomponentes la cosa es aún peor
el javelin por ejemplo se basa en el
avanzado motor de cohete de propulsor
sólido de la aeroyed rockettyle no hay
alternativas si esta empresa tiene un
problema o falla un proceso de
producción Punto Final otra empresa la
Williams International construye los
motores turbofan para la mayoría de los
misiles de cruceros sin ella no hay
alternativas y Así podríamos continuar
con una larga lista de ejemplos
es decir la competencia se ha reducido y
ya sabéis lo que eso supone menos
Innovación más coste menos capacidad de
producción Sobrante menos empleos y
mucha más dependencia en torno a lo que
pueda o no ocurrir con una determinada
empresa por ejemplo queréis un ejemplo
concreto Pues veréis según datos del
propio gobierno de Estados Unidos las
pequeñas empresas generan 16 veces y
media más patentes que los grandes
gigantes corporativos sin embargo
durante la última década el número de
pequeñas empresas en el complejo
Industrial militar norteamericano se ha
reducido un 40 por ciento pero como
sobre este tema ya os hablamos largo y
tendido en un vídeo que os dejamos abajo
en la descripción pasemos ya al cuarto
gran problema que hoy por hoy tienen las
fuerzas armadas de Estados Unidos alguna
idea de por dónde van los tiros pues
atentos axila
[Música]
mano de obra así de sencillo hace falta
mano de obra Estados Unidos está
atravesando su peor racha de
reclutamiento desde
1973 2022 fue un año malo y 2023 parece
que lo va a ser aún peor por ejemplo en
el ejercicio 2022 el ejército de tierra
se quedó 15.000 soldados por debajo de
su objetivo de tropas en 2023 el número
de efectivos puede reducirse en cerca de
20.000 unidades y esta forma se espera
que el ejercicio 2023 cierre con unos
450.000 soldados frente algo más de
500.000 que se consideran necesarios y
no se trata solo del US Army el resto de
cuerpos están en una situación muy
parecida incluso las academias militares
se están viendo afectadas por esta
crisis por ejemplo la solicitudes a la
academia de la fuerza aérea han caído un
28%. las de La Academia naval un 20%, y
la de la prestigiosa West Point un 10%.
esto exactamente Es lo que explican
noticias como la armada Cancela Las
bajas anticipadas y ofrece prórrogas
para que más marineros sigan vistiendo
el uniforme queridos amigos amigas en
Estados Unidos hay trabajo la tasa de
desempleo está en prácticamente mínimos
históricos Y eso se nota la Competencia
por los jóvenes trabajadores es muy alta
y las fuerzas armadas no escapan de esa
dinámica Pero ese no es el único
problema
[Música]
el grupo de jóvenes calificados para
unirse a las fuerzas armadas sin
necesitar ninguna excepción es cada vez
más y más pequeño problemas de visión de
asma de Salud Mental de obesidad
antecedentes desde el 2016 se ha pasado
del 29 al 23%. para colmo por diferentes
motivos las fuerzas armadas no están
atravesando su mejor momento en términos
de popularidad algunas encuestas
muestran que el nivel de confianza en
esta institución ha caído bastante en
los últimos años lo que hace que sea un
destino mucho menos atractivo encuesta
la confianza de las fuerzas armadas de
Estados Unidos se mantiene por debajo
del 50%. alrededor del 48% de los
estadounidenses dicen tener mucha
confianza en el ejército ligeramente por
encima del 45% del año pasado la
confianza en el ejército estadounidense
se ha desplomado en los últimos años en
2018 alrededor de 70% de los
norteamericanos dijeron que tenían mucha
confianza en la institución Y por último
tenemos el quinto gran problema Ni más
ni menos
este
nuevas amenazas y nuevas necesidades
[Música]
A ver no nos malinterpretes pese a todos
los problemas que hemos visto las
fuerzas armadas de Estados Unidos están
a otro nivel sin embargo eso no quiere
decir que no tenga grietas como ya
habéis visto las tienen Pues bien a
todos esos problemas tenemos que sumar
otra cuestión las nuevas necesidades
operativas hemos hablado de ello en un
montón de vídeos aquí en visualpolitik
China está modernizando su ejército a
toda pastilla y tiene una política
exterior cada vez más agresiva Rusia se
acaba de convertir en un adversario muy
poco fiable que además ha suspendido el
acuerdo New Start que limita el número
total de ojivas nucleares desplegadas la
Guerra de Ucrania ha puesto de
manifiesto muchas debilidades que ahora
se necesitan superar urgentemente fuera
del Norte se está convirtiendo en una
creciente amenaza nuclear e Irán parece
muy cerca de hacerse también con la
bomba
Estados Unidos asumirá un mayor riesgo
contra los misiles balísticos
intercontinentales norcoreanos en 2025
todo esto conllevará por ejemplo tener
que multiplicar el sistema de defensa
antimisiles porque estas nuevas
apuntan ya directamente al propio
territorio de Estados Unidos y sabéis
que si en la década de los 80 la
administración Reagan anunció la
iniciativa de defensa estratégica
popularmente conocida como Star Wars y
que contemplaba cientos y cientos de
interceptores terrestres y espaciales
montados en satélites hoy Estados Unidos
apenas cuenta con poco más de 40
interceptores terrestres ponerse al día
supondrá por supuesto mucho dinero y
muchas energías y estén están solo un
ejemplo
Pues bien aunque Estados Unidos es el
país que más gasta en defensa y que
tiene con mucha diferencia la mejor y
más poderosa fuerza militar estos que
habéis visto son los cinco grandes
problemas a los que se enfrentan hoy por
hoy las fuerzas armadas de Estados
Unidos para cumplir su gran objetivo
seguir manteniendo una enorme
superioridad militar respecto a
cualquier adversario por supuesto tener
a tus espaldas los bombarderos B1 y b2
los 180 furtivos f-22 los f-35 Los
Apaches los submarinos clase Ohio y
clase Virginia los misiles tomahawk los
portaaviones clase nimits y clase Ford
los abrams los más de 400 Jaimes o los
cerca de 1.200 m270 te hacen ser un
rival formidable y tal vez invencible
pero ya veis que todo se puede mejorar
pero llegamos hasta aquí turno para ti
creéis que Estados Unidos mantendrá su
hegemonía mundial Durante las próximas
décadas walkensáis que es el mayor
problema de todos logrará china ponerse
a su altura deja a nuestros impresiones
en los comentarios y hablamos debate ya
sabéis si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle al botón
de like y suscribiros avisalpolitik si
es que aún no lo habéis hecho y recordad
con el código policy que ha acabado en K
podéis disfrutar de un 83% de descuento
y 3 meses gratis de surfshark en link
como siempre abajo en la descripción una
vez más Muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]